from timcast.com
female swimmer assaulted by trans
activists while speaking on women's
rights quote this is proof that women
need sex protected spaces so you may
have seen the story this is about Riley
Gaines she is a woman's rights activist
I guess you'd call that a feminist who
has taken issue with with males
competing in female sports right she was
going to be speaking at an event and a
mob of far-left extremists chased her
into a room and then they pinned her
down for about three hours demanded
Ransom yeah they said make them pay us
pay us money that's extortion I guess
look at what happened with Brett
Weinstein and Evergreen yeah when they
were mocking and holding these
administrators hostage it's not the
first time yeah and if anybody doesn't
know the bread story which you should
either watch the Jordan Peterson or the
Mike Nana has a wonderful coverage of
that actually a long time ago produced a
miniature documentary well good at
Evergreen with Brett and so uh you can
you can search for Brett Weinstein
Evergreen Tim Cass or something I want
you on the show Brett if you're
listening so so what was the latest
development here with Riley Gaines oh so
what I wanted to talk about is is this a
story I had no question about it but
this kind of stuff this is an extreme
but it happened to Charles Murray I mean
it happens it happens all the time
what's really the story to me which
really the story is what the university
did they said that they were peaceful
protests they offered them counseling
they said transphobia has no place in
the university the statement if you
could pull the statement up it's an
utterly remarkable it's it's opposite
land and this is what is happening in
our universities and this is why
it's so important to talk about this
it's again what I had mentioned this is
the legitimacy Christ This is a crisis
of legitimacy institutions and this is
contributing to that this is the misuse
of the word phobia that's for sure
because saying that you don't want
biological men to compete in physical
sports with biological females or
doesn't mean you're afraid of trans or
women's prisons yeah it's not that
you're afraid of it I mean I'm not
afraid I just I'm concerned maybe and
it's not like this person's saying
anything radical she's crazy she's she's
just making logical political points
that that are are not out of the
ordinary and to have a group of people
chase her down to physically assault her
I mean I was chased by you know some of
these mobs before I was assaulted by one
of these mobs before it's not fun to
deal with but the police officers here
to to cower and not do anything here in
the university to back that it is here
it is it is a deranged statement and
anybody who reads that if you ever had
any question whatsoever that the
academies are ideologically captured
read their statements well so they New
York crosses some of it they say
following the Mayhem Jamila Moore vice
president for student affairs and
enrollment management emailed students
thanking them for taking part in the
event it took tremendous bravery to
stand in a challenging space I am proud
of the moments where we listened and
asked insightful questions I am also
proud of the moments when our students
demonstrated the value of free speech
and the right to protest peacefully
welcome to the modern area you see what
they did Free Speech right you see how
they chased her into a room demanded
money threatened her life all right
and they framed it under free speech
that's what they do
is someone playing something or
something
yeah I think someone's downstairs on
phone can you tell them their phone if
that's okay and that they're um yeah I
was I was actually just communicating
with Serge I missed the top part of the
quote that they said but they were happy
that the protests were peaceful they
weren't peaceful yeah look at what
happened with the Nashville six yeah
almost immediately you know the
Democrats they they what they start
saying the Nashville three they shift
the entire narrative to these Democrats
who get ousted for an Insurrection at
their state capital Insurrection you
think that all the institutions all the
colleges I mean obviously not all okay
this is a huge question so I don't know
if you've been following the work by
Chris Ruffo uh at new college in Florida
and other places so he is working hard
to dismantle diversity bureaucracies and
speaking of which we are in Austin and
one of the things that I'm doing is I'm
a founding faculty at the University of
Austin and there's been none of this
at the University of Austin I
can assure you there's none of this
how's that going is it is it is
it phenomenal phenomenal well over 100
million dollars we got whoa yeah is it a
new University or what yep yep it's free
speech University it's what a university
should be it's a university a
traditional University kind of why how
old is it now it's well it's the first
class we have a summer program The
Forbidden classes program it'll be
online 2024. we got to get a high-speed
rail in this city now well okay out here
we're gonna be able to spread out is it
is it online only no it's on ground only
on ground yeah and they have classes
this summer I'll be teaching the
Forbidden classes the Kathleen stock
with gender Mark and reason Neil
Ferguson ion her CLE how big how big is
it how many square feet what do you got
no we it's just it's literally being
constructed now wow it's in Austin but
so you ask a great question what
percentage of universities so I think a
question is what percentage of the
people believe are caught in the orbit
of the ideology we don't really know the
answer to that question because they've
been so successful at creating a culture
of fear that
people won't honestly admit if they
believe the these truly deranged
propositions so we don't really know but
we we know from whether or not there are
offices of diversity Equity inclusion
which are virtually every University if
not everyone maybe not Hillsdale Liberty
the conservative we know that there are
bias response teams at over 150
universities uh two excuse me 250
universities where you can and that's
from Julian Melcher in the Wall Street
Journal published that a few years ago
it's been updated where people can
students or anyone can file a report
that is lodged with the police if they
even for basically For Thought crimes so
our universities are experiencing
ideological capture this has been the
base of my disagreement with Tim the
base of my disagreement with Tim is that
this is the nucleation point this is the
point that it from which it all erupts
and what we haven't talked about at all
but I probably should mention because
it's so important for context is that
you I can't you know all my Publications
Etc or someone let me take it off myself
someone who has a lot of Publications
research go to Google Scholar teaching
deck or quarter Century of teaching Etc
et cetera I can't somebody like that
can't just go into the public schools
and start teaching you need a teaching
certificate all of the colleges of
Education that Grant teaching
certificates they're literally all of
them are woke they're predicated on
Paula first pedagogy the Press Jim James
Lindsay guest of your show your friend
also talks about this pretty extensively
this is a woke indoctrination meal for
teachers in K-12 systems and we get this
madness so
I think I just I disagree with you I
think you're wrong okay
what we saw with like um what was his
name uh Nick christakis was that his
name yeah Nicholas Christopher Nicholas
christakis Prince the students oh no
Yale Yale sorry freshman students
already had this ideology within them
right they brought it to the
universities correct and the
universities said the customer is always
right and then recycled back to them
what they were demanding right so they
okay but so you're actually making my
point unless I'm not understanding
you're not understanding okay these
these 16 year olds are on Facebook
they're they're 10 years old they get a
Facebook account they're not supposed to
but they do yeah they see nothing but
this weird algorithmic garbage they
enter the university and they demand
these changes and the schools say yes
because you pay our bills so you're
saying people from the University gate
keep who gets to teach at the elementary
school yeah we're not disagreeing
the point was the universe that's what
I'm sorry right what I'm saying is the
universities did not originate this the
there's elements of the ideology that
obviously you can trace back to Academia
what I'm saying is the universities have
these things within them because young
people were manipulated brought it to
the universities and demanded it okay so
if the causal explanation for this is
solely algorithmic manipulation then how
is it given that you yourself have said
there are an awful lot of ideologies
then how is it that it's a what an
utterly remarkable coincidence that's
the ideology taught in universities and
it's the same one that the ideology
pushes that's way too much when did it
become when did we start seeing these
these protests this this uproar the far
left experiments it's been over the past
10 years it has quite literally been
since Lexus Nexus status points out the
emergence of social media Around the
World created an expansion of this
ideology it seems like you're both have
a touch of my side bias because you're a
student of the internet Tim and you're a
student of the Academia it seems and
you're both right it's a Confluence of
events
he's disagreeing with me which is fine
what I'm saying fine what I'm saying is
the algorithms Amplified our our our
mental our world view at the same time
as we started seeing the emergence of
the far left stuff we also saw an
expansion of white nationalism I got it
critical pedagogy started before social
media so critic critical pedagogy was
the precursor to that those people got
social media Alyssa all these people
they are innocent they actually are you
know everybody wants to be a victim this
is John Heights is a victim culture it
is a victim culture but they are
actually victims they're epistemic
victims of a deranged ideology those
people
were then placed in seats of power from
K through 12 up they've been getting
that so the kids who came to Yale
they've been indoctrinated with that
stuff for years thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time